[Musique]
8 à 13 sur ces 8 après espagne argentine
en match seul match qui est marrant tu
dormes ici c'est comme d'alors sa
démarche sa place en exprime sa démarche
juste après et wii motion allait très
bien super ça là bas très bas on est
contente de vous brancher il à son
portable d'ici d'avoir une urgence on
commence par tout ce qu'il fallait pas
tel à telle heure par heure ces
dernières 24 heures avec et ça paie
loriot et valider sa fille je salue
également je suis tous les coups palau
je vais tout le monde ça sent bien que
ça va c'est pour gagner rien n'est pas
il faut pas rêver faut faire attention
la voie aux passes quand elle s'énerve
on dirait qu'elles doublent l'âne dans
shrek journée avec un jeu de la
longévité la primeur jean téléfoot ya
christian jeanpierre a voulu faire le
jones avec son chroniqueur tu sens que
même le stagiaire de 3e le respecte pas
il prend avant une spéciale à
l'élastique c'est parti
[Musique]
on va tout cas pas aux urgences ya les
infirmières qui sont filmés 24 heures
sur 24 des personnes les a prévenus
visiblement en tout cas faut pas qu'elle
retourne au portugal tout de suite tout
de suite en madame on va devoir vous
seule une petite plus de 100 un petit
mot disant fortunés
je cherchais je vous connais tous les
courses de nascar aux états unis à part
thomas des anges dix pensent que c'est
une course de bad boy
aujourd'hui on va se faire leurs courses
deux lascars avait dit la fia et c'était
sport aujourd'hui dans l'équipe de tpm
fait tout le monde était à la salle
mokhtar déjà qui a pas mal galéré à que
l'élastique
[Musique]
galéré et valérie bénaïm aussi c'était
traction pour maléré aujourd'hui elle en
forme valauchan suit les images des
gîtes et les enfants la gare du bfm tous
les soirs à 20h
ont-elles écrit à frais c'est l'émission
ça 20h et ce avec ruth elkrief d'autres
en route donc pour une émission qui
tient la route aux connecting people
je crois que c'est que filou techniciens
du son il a une dent contre route parce
que et c'est juste la fin du plateau ce
très rapide mais elle dit un truc
fallait lui couper le micro un petit peu
avant c'est pas le genre de route furent
les précisions apportées ce soir lors de
sa conférence de presse par le procureur
mme hollins sur bfm parler aurélie
blondel a l'air vraiment d'apprécier
l'animateur de la météo ses marques et
ça fait plaisir de la petite couronne
à bientôt 6h40 un mot du temps du jour
avec marquer le temps pas terrible comme
marquer
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui petit
enfant de star sur kad merad
il a loué la boulette avec cyril lignac
on l'a vu dans vos enfants ah oui
en
la partition
à tabac comme vous sur la toile
et là tu as des expertes et à du lourd
attend une nouvelle émission de m6 c'est
un peu comme koh lanta sauf que nonce
comme koh lanta enfin que ça animé par
stéphane rotenberg
saleh qui quand ils animent top chef il
fait des photos comme ça et quand il
anime une émission d'aventuré il fait
découvrir nos remarques
avec ce look survivants qui fait de l'
aventure comme ça c'est une bombe de
bègles qui fait de la voiture comme
saturn de boîtes comme ça comme dans
toute émission laventure y avait ces
princes à l'aller d'effritement de
beaucoup d'efforts aux éventuels zava
peut parler regardez bien le dire que
j'avance et plus je me sens mal qu'on
fasse un arrêt et vous avez un arrêt
pourquoi pour monter une tente pour
faire du feu pour se ravitailler bah non
pas au wild en faut qu'on fasse un arrêt
djari samuel lui sont hyper bien sorti
un détail près il pourra plus avoir
d'enfant après l' aventure je pense
le chef cuisinier a le plus grand mal à
trouver ses appuis et à mettre un pied
devant l'autre
même si bien candidat totalement de
mauvaise foi quand on lui demande s'il a
eu peur
c'est sympa pas méchant mais je te
bouges pas peur non pas du tout si vous
avez parlé des brocarts mes cadeaux
voici les preuves commenté par notre
patrick montel les pronos de la gauche
[Musique]
soit lui attention à lui tout à l'heure
il a été monstrueux david combat qui à
mon avis va aller très loin kubacki
alors que derrière on souffre
terriblement pas
j'avais porté la poisse aux länder
la température va regarder ça pendant
des heures j'adore toutefois que j'adore
parler de slam à hélène lam repas us
lawe alors pourquoi cela veut tout
simplement vassal et cyril est cool
cyril féraud animateurs ils aiment bien
laisser aux gens le temps de faire des
petites dédicace à la fin ouais mais
c'est que les candidats de france 3 ils
ont rarement 27 pige quoi donc ils ont
beaucoup de gens il faut faire des
dédicaces sept ans et demi de dédicaces
est ce que vous êtes amusé evelyne oui
oui bon endroit ce qui rendent partir
alors on a brand s alfred mes enfants
jean-charles et maryse marie juliette et
arnaud d'accord mes petits-enfants
antoine alexandre gauthier philippe
louis clara et charlotte
oui nos amis en général dont une amie
qui n'a pas pu venir aujourd'hui et tous
les gens les ont travaillé avec moi
merci beaucoup différence de taille
entre les candidats il ne s'y attendait
pas
joli
[Applaudissements]
sept à huit langues c'est comme sept à
huit mais sans sucre on a vu le fruit de
l'union entre franck dubosc et gilles
verdez cadeau il ya quelques riant là
c'est le la presse à un petit peu mais
s'est mis à encore embêter ça va nous
vous ça très bien un salut tu as les
qualités mais j'ai vu n'était pas bien
bah oui partie la durite hausses qui là
pascal mais j'ai d'autres riches en pas
une grosse envie toi michel denisot a vu
qu'il ya derrière moi où j'ai même pas
vu
bah oui il est là je vous regarde le dos
plusieurs les fesses de skieurs toi
merci j'ai pas compris la défaite eux et
elles sont comment les tests de ce qui
est des cuisses très très importante on
sent qu'ils aient beaucoup de nuits du
schuss
y en a marre il ya du bien serait donc
ça donne un supplément de très belles
fesses c'est le plan de bâton a semé
merci julien maire michel denisot il
anime en off sur paris-première celui-ci
recevait carla bruni malheureusement il
a faim lapsus qui passe mal quand tu
t'adresses à l'ex première dame
ça fait deux fois qu'il double fait ce
lapsus en effet peut-être exprès
on arrive à la fin de ce rendez vous je
vous remercie beaucoup
salut les terriens on a pu voir que
didier bourdon à passer un vrai bon
moment ils en loupe pas une miette
didier bourdon vous préférez la
compagnie de votre maman vous dire
j'étais le mary et max
[Musique]
donc c'est les 30 ans de m6 boutique ils
ont décidé de fêter ça en montrant tous
ceux qui bossent avec eux en coulisses
c'est sympa d'aider les siens en direct
sans problème c'est moi le catalogue
c'est moi et pour vous accueillir au
téléphone dans la joie et la bonne
humeur c'est bon on parole d'expert
c'est moi cet écolier avec six mois de
retard c'est moi les appels surtaxés à
134 euros la minute c'est moi et moi est
celui qui a pété c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
j'aime ça dans la quête d'action ici ils
ont rediffusé c'est mon épisode préféré
jeter obligé de vous leur passé c'est
des policiers qui tentent d'interpeller
un gars il veut pas ouvrir sa porte il y
en a au fond il dit ou c'est vous et
kopa je vais là dessus me font ces sept
tomes au final tout reprend comme si
s'était rien passé de l'ocs
non
[Applaudissements]
monsieur au cynisme et que vous savez au
moins dépenses
faites un vote j'ai maté numéro 23 on a
vu une militaire qui fait foirer des
interviews y perdre sérieuse de son
supérieur et enfin conseil au
publicitaire brésilien comme ont posé
des pubs sur des bus tout on le fait
penser à l'importance du placement du
pot d'échappement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai oublié de vous dire que j'avais des
génériques chantés
j'adore ça tu générique chanté c'est
simple ça on est génériquement et que la
musique et on y mange on chante les
paroles que ce serait fait l'émission
tort joie décrivait et yann nouveautés
pmp le rendez-vous des médecins
traitants qui ont fait des études
jusqu'à 35 ans ils disent toujours pour
te faire flipper que la gastro st
dans cette année la seule émission qui
parle d'année saisi tout en faisant des
blagues sur des grosses divine
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
pour magazines une météo d'une heure
elle était passif ouf l'idée mais il y
avait que romejko de dispo pour l'animer
sans claude bertrand des chiffres et des
lettres est absent mais c'est quand même
super chiant bonjour à tous merci nous
rejoindre sur france 3
deux ans où il devance surtout celle où
tu n'as pas
à gauche à quelques pas croire qu'en ce
jour entre
[Musique]
c'est là où il mangeait blanquette de
veau bonjour à tous et si je vous disais
que jean-luc de faire gauler jean-mi
auraient pu s'ils s'avèrent siku les
peuples du sahel n'a toujours pas
terminé
l'anecdote commencé au mois de janvier l
empêchement d'un chroniqueur montiel le
remplace dans le quart d'heure que jean
denis a été reporter de guerre mais
c'est dans tpm paix qu'il a pris le plus
cher qui est beaucoup plus épanouie
occulter la ouvert une crêperie les
crêpes derrière roland garros dans un
mois et demi casteil sur d'animer tous
les vendre
passé avec son nom impossible de faire
une lime
[Applaudissements]